There is a list going
around Twitter today
of the top ten
most dangerous celebrities.
I wonder who could be
at number seven.
Probably Suge Knight,
or Suge Knight, or Suge.
Let's see who it is.
What? It's Chris Hardwick?
I don't...
-How am I... dangerous?
-(applause and cheering)
No, no, no, no.
Has nothing to do with me,
although I'm very honored.
I never get put
on lists like this.
I really feel like I've made it.
I don't know
if I should be upset
that they called me dangerous,
or considered me less dangerous
than Carson Daly,
who's a very nice guy.
He's a very nice guy.
But this alarming graphic
is actually McAfee's list
of the top ten
most dangerous celebrities
to search for online,
meaning that cyber criminals
use our names
to expose you to malware.
Ironically, John McAfee is not
anywhere on this list...
(laughter)
...who is the most dangerous
person in the world.
So don't click on anything
that sounds too fake,
like "Chris Hardwick nip slip."
Um...
-(laughter)
-It's a trap.
I don't have nipples. Uh...
(laughter)
Well, I do have nipples,
but you don't want to...
All right, fine,
fine, fine, fine.
(applause and cheering)
Oops. Oops.
How did that get out?
-Oops.
-Oh, my.
You want some of that little
sand dollar action for you?
(laughter)
That accidentally... flew out.
Comedians,
what's a computer virus
you'd get from Googling
one of these celebrities?
Dave Foley.
Uh, if you Google Daniel Tosh,
your computer kicks you
in the balls
and thinks it's the funniest
thing that ever happened.
-All right, points. Points.
-(laughter, applause & cheering)
Suzy Nakamura.
Um, if you Google Selena Gomez,
your computer gets whatever
virus Justin Bieber has.
-All right, points.
-(laughter and groaning)
(applause and cheering)
Ken.
Well, he's not on the list,
but if you Google Joel McHale,
your computer gets so smug and
snarky, but is just so (bleep)!
HARDWICK:
All right.